[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre set et
loisirs du jeudi 22 novembre tout de
suite le sommaire de ce dixième numéro
depuis le 17 novembre c'est la semaine
du jeu à saint quentin en yvelines de
gros événements ce week-end pour
clôturer marie pierre cariou elle émane
là quoi sur moi avec nous que nous en
présenter les règles 16e rencontre
internationale de capoeira organisé par
le club vélo horizon de ce samedi le 23
novembre
ils vous invitent à venir découvrir ce
sport de combat artistique jean dujardin
et bérénice béjo dans dix artistes
ryan gosling emma stone dans la la land
les comédies musicales peuvent être de
véritables succès la philharmonie de
paris propose de revenir sur les plus
grandes d'entre elles l'hiver et sa
fraîcheur arrive plus qu'est-ce qu'ils
vont sortir ou allume son chauffage et
on joue aux jeux de société en famille
justement depuis samedi 7 novembre c'est
la fête du jeu à saint quentin en
yvelines le réseau des médiathèques a
concocté tout un programme pour nous
avec nous en plateau marie-pierre
caruhel chargée du développement
culturel du réseau des médiathèques et
manon lacroix agents patrimoine de la
médiathèque du canal bonjour bonjour
bonjour alors on va pas faire de partir
tout de suite mais quand même pour se
mettre dans l'ambiance vous propose de
regarder ce reportage de michael et demi
d'euros et nicolas landry au festi
jeunes week-end du 17 et 18 novembre
une bonne dose de rire et d'amusement à
villepreux la commune organisé son 4e
festival du jeu au complexe sportif
alain mimoun
au programme 18 heures de jeu sur le
week end le festi jeu c'est un
rendez-vous pour toute la famille
qui comprend des jeux de société des
jeux vidéo des jeux jeunesse et qui a
pour vocation de permettre à chacun de
passer un bon moment pendant deux jours
dans la salle on a gagné on a perdu et
les visiteurs ont pu découvrir de
nouveaux jeux moins connus du grand
public
alors le jeu consiste à gagner
non sérieusement en fait c'est la soeur
de dominos les dominos intelligent en
plaçant des tuiles ça nous permet de
gagner des ressources et ensuite la
façon d'utiliser les ressources ça me
permet de gagner des points
vous ferez utilisation et moi j'aime
bien jean qu'on ferait des civilisations
en parallèle des jeux de société une
association proposait aux visiteurs de
se glisser dans la peau d'un guerrier du
moyen-âge à travers un jeu de rôle ici
vous n'entendrez pas le fracas des épées
les hommes sont en mousse là les entités
qu'on fait ça va le faire découvrir aux
plus jeunes un peu bas à prendre un peu
à se battre avec des armes qui sont
sécurisées et avec des gestes qu'ils
sont
alors ici fait le plus esthétique
possible quoi au total le festival du
jeu accueilli ce week-end la plus de
2500 personnes des chiffres en constante
augmentation
la partie n'est peut-être pas encore
terminée alors on l'a vu la semaine du
jeu à commencer par une large découverte
et ça s'est poursuivi de toute la
semaine dans les médiathèques
marie-pierre effectivement dans toutes
les médiathèques du réseau de
saint-quentin des ateliers jeux étaient
ont été programmées notamment mercredi
21 donc on est 22 hier et puis certaines
médiathèque propose du jeu toute la
semaine avec
du retrogaming offert à maurepas et des
jeux en bois par exemple la médiathèque
saint-ex à voisins alors organiser ce
type d'événement ça fait partie des
missions du réseau des médiathèques ça
fait partie des missions et du réseau le
jeu est aujourd'hui un objet culturel
légitimer
c'est vrai qu'on peut entendre encore
certaines critiques qu'est ce que le jeu
fait en médiathèque
on a aujourd'hui le débat qu'on a autour
du jeu un débat un peu identique à celui
qu'on avait sur la bd j'irai dans les
années 70 80
aujourd'hui le jeu c'est une pratique
culturelle qui concerne toutes les
tranches d'âge toutes les catégories
sociales
j'irai même toutes les cultures et en
tant que tel le jeu à sa toute sa place
un médiathèque
ce sont des collections les médiathèques
ont constitué des collections de jeux de
société de jeux vidéo et donc autour de
ses collections nous proposons des
animations ponctuelles chaque semaine ou
tous les quinze jours certains nombres
de médiathèque propose des ateliers jeux
de société jeux vidéo sur différents
créneaux et puis la voilà la semaine du
jeu c'est un peu l'aboutissement de tous
ces projets que nous menons toutes que
nous menons toute l'année pas pas qu'une
semaine dans l'année mais là c'est
vraiment le point d'orgue le point
d'orgue toute la semaine et ce week-end
pour clôturer un peu cette semaine en
fanfare avec la nuit du jeu imed oui
c'est ça donc la nuit du jeu au muy met
donc pour appeler musées de la ville
médiathèque du canal où la sera un
événement entre
20h et minuit ou les publier qu'ils
soient famille amis pour venir jouer
ensemble donc à des jeux en bois jeux de
société jeux vidéo découvrir des jeux du
monde entier avec certaines personnes il
y aura aussi un coin pour les petits on
n'oublie pas donc à partir de 2 ans et
toutes les animations sont animés par
les bibliothécaires et par des
associations locales donc notamment
faire du bridge avec l'association de
montigny il y aura également du tarot
des échecs lanusquets minuit c'est
gratuit on le précise tout est gratuit
il n'y a pas besoin de réserver
tout le monde est bienvenu pendant toute
la soirée donc ça c'est samedi soir et
le dimanche ça se passe à la commanderie
avec une murder party en musique et de
ghayne exactement donc une murder party
donc c'est un événement où les gens
peuvent mener l enquête savoir qui a
commis un crime où le crime a été commis
il ya un lien avec l'exposition en cours
c'est exactement ça cirque en fête
dimanche sera la dernière journée pour
venir découvrir l'expo corps mouvement
et innovation organisé par l'atelier des
sciences à la commanderie dernier jour
de l'expo et c'est là qu'a eu lieu en
fait un crime et les participants ont
deux heures pour six des sept minimes
alors ça c'est sur réservation cse
réservation des places mais il reste
très très peu de places là c'est vrai
qu'on puisse que de faire quelques déçus
il reste une vingtaine de places sur la
murder de 17h30 sachant qu'il ya deux
créneaux voilà là à 14h on a déjà fait
le plein il reste encore quelques places
à 17h30 qui est aussi un escape game et
pour ce conte par une place ya des jeux
en accès libre
voilà il ya une salle qui va être dédiés
à des jeux de société et quelques jeux
d'adressé qui permettront aussi
personnes qui ne peuvent pas avoir accès
aux escaliers il ya deux et ce clavier
mais quand même
mais comme les
les eskers pour fait se pratique à 5
sont des créneaux à 5
c'est très très vite rempli sur sur
l'après midi la murder rien là c'est
pour cent participants donc un petit peu
plus de marge
et donc voilà les déçus des eskers
pouder murder pourront passer quelques
moments à jouer aux jeux de société où
je donnerai ce très bien merci à vous
d'être venu sur notre plateau je vous
laisse retourner à vos plateaux de jeu
et si vous voulez les rejoindre dans la
partie la fête du jeu continue vous
pouvez retrouver le programme sur le
site internet sorties insolites la
commune d'orson ville organise une
chasse à l'aigle les rapaces ont béni
pendant la messe avant d'être lancée
après leur proie
rendez vous samedi à l'église à partir
de 9 heures l'antenne locale de
l'association française pour la
recherche sur la trisomie 21
vous fera danser samedi 24 novembre à la
salle gauguin à partir de 19h30
une soirée musette en présence de
l'accordéoniste local christian de
l'audi une tombola est également prévu
les bénéfices de la soirée seront
reversés à la recherche sur cette
anomalie génétique et pour votre rendez
vous cinéma patrick jacques de dixmude
vous amène au ciné cet élan cours avec
une soirée spéciale pour la lutte contre
l'illettrisme alors cette semaine au
ciné c'est une avant première
exceptionnelle en partenariat avec le
lion's club pour lutter contre
l'illettrisme dimanche à 18h15 la
projection du film rémi sans famille
avec daniel auteuil
le tarif est exceptionnel parce qu'il ya
une partie des recettes qui sera versée
à la lutte contre l'illettrisme via le
lions club voilà et la semaine prochaine
le niveau la nouvelle le nouvel opus du
festival saint quentin festival du film
documentaire dont il ya plein de choses
qui vont se dérouler du 28 novembre au 2
décembre notamment
soirée exceptionnelle le 29 à l'ugc la
soirée d'ouverture en présence des
frères bogdanoff et la soirée de clôture
qui se déroulera le 2 décembre à partir
de 16 heures au ciné cette avec la
projection de 16 levers de soleil qui
sera suivie de la remise du prix tv 60
18 du prix des cinémas et des prix du
public parce que le public peut voter
pour ceux qui ont préféré parler sept
documentaires en compétition et tout
cela sera suivi d'un cocktail le plus
chaleureux possible nous le souhaitons
bien sûr pour toutes ces informations
vous pouvez vous inscrire et aussi pour
ses soirées sur le site ww point 50-1
point fr le club de capoeira d'elancourt
belo horizonte organise ce samedi 23
novembre ces 16e rencontres
internationales un baptême pour les
débutants qui obtiendront leur première
ceinture et une montée en grade pour les
plus confirmés
de nombreux maîtres de la discipline
seront seront présents dont un qui vient
exceptionnellement du brésil ils
viendront partager leur expérience avec
la centaine d'adhérentes club maistre
touchés et deux de ses élèves étaient en
plateau du 7-8 journal mardi 20 novembre
viennent de loin il il va nous apporter
toujours des nouvelles expériences de
nouveaux mouvements et c'est ça qu'on
aime on aime apprendre de nouvelles
choses
la capoeira est en bois dont un petit
lot de la danse de la musique des sons
des mouvements des combats de situer
acrobatique attendant qui a tous des
dons et les rencontres sportives où
donner de la voix comme supporters ce
week end le club de plaisir reçoit de
guyancourt en première division de
district un match qui s'annonce tendu
les deux équipes ne sont pas ne sont
séparés que par 3 points après huit
journées pour suivre la rencontre c'est
samedi 24 novembre au stade bernard
giroux a plaisir à 15 heures toujours à
plaisir l'équipe de fédérale 2 de rugby
reçoit arras pour cette dixième journée
de compétition les plaisirs roy devront
tenir face à unique dernière du
classement à qui donnera tout pour
remonter match ce dimanche 25 novembre à
15 heures à 15 heures au stade robert
barran
à plaisir elle nous donne envie de
danser et nous laissent leurs mélodies
en tête les comédies musicales sont un
genre cinématographique à part entière
et font partie intégrante de l'histoire
du 7e art la philharmonie de paris vous
immerge dans ce monde tout en couleur
avec une exposition jusqu'au 27 janvier
reportage en musique avec nicolas le
hérissé de nos confrères via grand paris
mamma mia
les demoiselles de rochefort lalaland la
simple évocation de ces comédies
musicales nous donne envie de pousser la
chansonnette et reproduire les
chorégraphies dans une vaste exposition
immersive la philharmonie de paris nous
invite à passer derrière le décor à
découvrir ce qu'est véritablement une
comédie musicale
et pourquoi séduisait l'otan aujourd'hui
le succès des comédies musicales en fait
c'est cyclique c'est-à-dire il ya
parfois de longues périodes où c'est
censé ne pas marcher et comme ça marche
moins bien les producteurs investissent
moins et du coup ça se décline un peu il
suffit qu'ils aient un projet qui marche
comme la lalonde récemment qui a été un
succès planétaire pour que tout d'un
coup le genre redeviennent populaires je
crois aussi que le jeune public
d'aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire un lit les
enfants les adolescents sont plus
ouverts à ce genre qu'elle a commis
musical que leurs parents voire leurs
grands parents surtout en france où on
se méfie et un petit peu de ce genre qui
est eux qui est un peu frivole peu
futiles léger du célèbre chantons sous
la pluie en passant par le succès récent
de la la land l'exposition revient sur
les débuts des comédies musicales le
contexte historique des années 20 aux
états unis et l'âge d'or des studios
hollywoodiens
vous découvrirez tous les ingrédients
propices à une bonne comédie musicale
ainsi que les costumes du cultissime
peau d'âne et comment ont-elles évolué
au fil des décennies ce qui a beaucoup
évolué dans l'histoire de la comédie
musicale c'est finalement le
l'histoire des traditions ou des goûts
musicaux mais par contre c'est
intéressant de noter que les scénaristes
finalement il raconte presque toujours
les mêmes histoires puisque ils se sont
cassés de la tête depuis le début dans
la recherche de sujets qui pouvait
accueillir de façon la plus naturelle
possible du chant et de la danse et les
plus motivés pourront s'essayer aux
claquettes avec le claquettistes du film
the artist en personne une exposition
qui nous offre un panorama musical pour
découvrir la richesse des comédies
musicales d'hier et d'aujourd'hui et
c'est la fin de votre cette lutte
loisirs je vous retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
d'ici là bonne semaine sur tv 78
[Musique]
oh